wilkovit has also hit the cmt awards
co-host kelsey ballerini recently tested
positive for the virus and will now
perform her duties remotely still the
show will go on tonight right here on
channel 8.
[Music]
katelyn smith who is nominated for her
first cmt music award is getting ready
to perform at tonight's show on cbs i
grew up
watching cmt as a little girl watching
the cmt awards and then now that it has
a platform like cbs it's just even more
exciting and more people will get to see
it which is great
[Music]
kane brown leads this year's nominations
with four and not only will he be
performing he is now also co-hosting
along with kelsey ballerini and actor
anthony mackey after ballerini tested
positive for coving i'm just so excited
to get to do it again i was honestly
kind of bummed when i found out that you
only do it two years in a row and then
they pass it on to somebody else so i'm
glad i get to come back and do it
ballerini who is up for three awards is
still co-hosting and performing but from
home i still have five outfit changes
and i'm wearing them all it's gonna be a
good time
me him ballerini you don't want to miss
it so many of country music's biggest
names will be taking the stage including
jimmy allen and miranda lambert who was
wearing her vintage the judd's t-shirt
when we caught up with her in
anticipation of the grammy-winning
mother-daughter duo's first televised
performance in decades this performance
is so
i guess the word is radical
you'll see we'll see indeed it promises
to be a highlight in a night of great
music
all right you can catch the cmt awards
at 8 o'clock right here on channel 8
followed by 8 news now at 11 o'clock